good evening my name is Claire Hughes
and I'm a sophomore from Ann Arbor
Michigan studying politics and French
tonight I have the honor of introducing
our next speaker mrs. Minnie Churchill
she's the director of Churchill Heritage
which holds the copyright to the artwork
of Sir Winston
she was co-author along with David
Coombs of Sir Winston Churchill his life
and his paintings mrs. Churchill was
responsible for tracing star Winston's
500-plus paintings across the world and
learning the stories associated with
their ownership she spent six years in
this pursuit and gave her interests in
the resulting book - Churchill heritage
mrs. Churchill is the grand
daughter-in-law of the late Sir Winston
lady Churchill and was married to
Winston Churchill Member of Parliament
for 25 years she serves as the deputy
left tenant of Dorset and has been on
the independent managing board for the
UK home office to Portland young
offenders president for ten years she
has served on the management committee
of st. Catherine's hospice as a trustee
of the National benevolent fund for the
aged international trust for the Nature
Conservancy please join me now in
welcoming the new Churchill to the stage
good evening ladies and gentlemen
Claire thank you so much for your very
kind introduction
it was greatly appreciated it's a huge
privilege to be here at Hillsdale
tonight and I would like to thank
Douglas Jeffery for inviting me to be at
your wonderful College and for so many
people for making Simon and me
so welcome before I start my talk I
would like to say how thrilled my family
is that dr. Larry Owens is completing
the companion volumes of the great
biography of Winston Churchill that
martin gilbert was unable to finish I've
seen the latest volume of 950,000 words
which is absolutely fascinating and he's
been so beautifully printed on special
paper which I believe came from
Hillsdale Winston Churchill had such an
amazing life and it's extraordinary how
every day of his life seems to have been
so well documented it's 50 years since
Winston Churchill died and a hundred
years since he started painting my
lecture will be on Winston Churchill and
his paintings
I will first talk about Sir Winston and
then Simon who is here with me and I
will show you a selection of his
paintings and also some photographs
together with David Coombs the art
historian I have recently finished a
book on the paintings it took us six
years and we managed to track down over
500 of his paintings and one sculpture I
knew sir Winston only in the very last
years of his amazing life the first time
that I met him was in 1963 when Winston
grandson of Sir Winston invited me to
lunch with him and his grandfather at 28
Hyde Park Gate which was the London home
of Sir Winston and lady Churchill
I was rather nervous I didn't know very
much about politics and wondered what he
would talk about however I need not have
been well he had a wonderful time with
my Winston talking to his grandfather
about a flight he had recently made
around Africa in a single-engine
airplane so Winston then proceeded to
talk about his travels in Africa as a
young man and in particular he talked
about his experiences in the Boer War
just before the end of lunch Sir Winston
rang the bell for the butler and asked
him to bring the cream jug back he
poured the cream directly onto the
dining room table and chock his lovely
ginger cat jumped onto his lap and then
onto the table where he lapped up the
cream I thought how special it was that
he cared so much about his cat I hated
to think what lady Churchill would have
thought that summer
Winston drove me down to chart war the
Churchill's lovely home in Kent the
house was empty and we had a wonderful
time exploring the garden with his
beautiful view across the Weald of Kent
and we then went into the house I could
not believe what I saw in the dining
room there were stacked on the floor row
upon row of canvases hundreds of
paintings I knelt down to have a closer
look at the paintings there were
magnificent landscapes seascapes
still lives as well as the occasional
portrait I knew that Winston painted but
I had no idea that he was so prolific I
also had no idea that some 20 years
later I would be running church or
heritage which owns the copyright to the
paintings painting became a very
important part of Winston's life Winston
started painting in 1915 it was after
Gallipoli
and the disastrous Dardanelles campaign
when he lost his government job as First
Lord of the Admiralty he thought his
career was finished many years later
Clementine Churchill was to tell
Winston's biographer Martin Gilbert that
looking back over all the events and
crises through which they both had lived
and in which wisdom had played a major
part none had been more searing as the
drawn-out campaign of the Dardanelles
with its heavy toll of life and bitter
aftermath my grandfather
major HJ Samet was killed at Gallipoli
he was in the Essex Regiment my
grandmother never put the blame on
Winston Churchill she always told our
family that Admiral Fisher was to bring
because he delayed the invasion and as a
result the Germans and the Turks were
waiting for them that summer Winston and
Clementine rented a small house called
howl farm near Godalming in Surrey they
would weekend there with their free
children Diana
Sarah and Randolph Clementine Churchill
described her husband stooped in deepest
thought pacing up and down the long
grass path at the top of the garden from
the cups of young trees at one end to
the wooden summerhouse at the other
nothing could distract him
she despaired of ever seeing him I'm
worried his depression are frightened
her he could find no comfort or
relaxation
Clementine Churchill lady told Martin
Gilbert that she felt he would die of
grief I felt that without the discovery
of painting he surely might have done
Winston in a most moving article
published in the 1920s wrote when I left
the Admiralty at the end of May 1915 I
remained a member of the cabinet and of
the war council in this position I knew
everything and could do nothing the
change from the intense executive
activities of each
today's work at the airport II to the
narrowly measured duties of a counselor
left me gasping like a Seabees fish from
the depths or a diver too suddenly
hoisted my veins threatened to burst
from the fall of pressure I had great
anxiety and no means of relieving it
I had Fierman convictions and small
power to give effect to them I had to
watch the unhappy casting away of great
opportunities and the feeble execution
of plans which I had launched and in
which I heartily believed I had a long
hours of utter unwanted leisure in which
to contemplate the frightful unfolding
of the war and at a moment when every
fiber of my being was inflamed in action
I was forced to remain a spectator of
the tragedy placed cruelly in a front
seat and then it was that the muse of
painting came to my rescue out of
charity and out of chivalry
because after all she had nothing to do
with me and she said all these toys any
good for you
they amuse some people it happened like
this one weekend his sister-in-law Guney
was staying with them and Winston
discovered her painting in watercolors
in the garden he watched her for a few
minutes and then borrowed her brush and
tried his hand of painting he was
immediately hooked very soon he was
experimenting with oils buying all the
equipment that he needed he wrote to
have reached the age of 40 without ever
handling a brush or fiddling with a
pencil to have regarded would
materialize the painting of any kind as
a mystery to have stood a pond the
pavement in front of a street artist and
then to suddenly find oneself plunged in
the middle of a new and intense form of
interest an action with paints and
pallets
Galvis and not to be discouraged by
results is an astonishing and enriching
experience the next step he found more
difficult and as he described in his
wonderful data book
painting as a pastime I started with the
sky it was on that occasion blue and
lady he describes how very gently I
mixed a little blue paint on the palette
with a very small brush and then with
infinite precaution made a mark about as
big as a beam a beam upon the front his
snow-white shield it was a challenge a
deliberate challenge but so subdued so
halting indeed so cataleptic that he
deserved no response at that moment the
loud approaching sound of a motor car
was heard in the drive and from this
chariot their steps swiftly and lightly
none other than the gifted wife of Sir
John Lavery painting but what are you
hesitating about let me have a brush the
big one splash into the turpentine
wallop into the bloom white frantic
flash on the palette then no longer
clean and then several large fair
strokes and splashes of brew on the
absolutely cowering canvas anyone could
see that he could not hit back no evil
fate avenged the jaunty violence the
canvas grinned in helplessness before me
the spell was broken the sickly
inhibitions rolled away I seized the
largest brush and fell upon my victim
with berserk fury and I have never felt
any ore of a canvas since and that's
quoting Winston Churchill Winston was
lucky indeed to have such gifted mentors
as John and Hazel Lavery to guide his
earliest brushstrokes and what had been
a pleasing acquaintance now grew into a
warming and lasting friendship after
that Winston spent as much time as he
possibly could in Sir John Lavery studio
painting with Alerus who were both
talented artists
Lavery taught him how to paint
landscapes interiors and portraits and
one of his earliest paintings was of
John Lavery at his easel in 1915 this he
gave to Lavery who lent it to the Royal
Society of portrait painters for their
exhibition in 1919 this was the first
time one of Winston's works was
exhibited in his biography John Lavery
wrote I know few amateur wielders of the
brush with a cleaner sense of light and
color or assure a grasp of essentials
had he chosen painting instead of
statesmanship I believe he would have
been a great master with the brush at
the end of November 1915 Winston decided
to resign completely from the government
and as he was also a major in the Oxford
yeoman dream he decided he would like to
join them in France where they were
fighting major Churchill initially
served for the second battalion of the
Grenadier Guards and subsequently he was
made colonel of the 6th battalion Royal
Scots Fusiliers which was resting after
heavy losses in action
Colonel Churchill threw himself into
this job with zest
he found the details of military life
absorbing and gave himself over entirely
to the daily affairs of his battalion
only Clementi knew of his bitterness he
felt in his heart for the politicians at
home in a letter to her he says I do not
ever show anything but a smiling face to
the military world a proper complete
detachment and contentment but Sir it is
a relief to write one's heart out to you
he wrote on the 10th of January 1916
Clementine was not the only the trusted
and sympathetic recipient of his
confidence she was also a perceptive
informant concerning political
personalities and affairs on the firm
front Winston and clementines letters to
each other during the four months he was
to be at the front form a deeply moving
correspond
and in January 1916 they moved to a
village named plug Street on the Belgium
border this was very close to the front
line he wrote I shall only move back
about three quarter mile from the front
line when we are in support and supposed
to be resting thereafter for the next
two to three months which are all dwell
continuously in close range of the
enemy's artillery their headquarters was
at Lawrence farm it was here that
Winston painted several pictures of the
desolate scene and one of his officers
Edmund Bakewell Smith then aged 24
described how Winston started painting
the second or third time he went up to
the farm each time we were in the line
he spent more time on his paintings
gradually to the courtyard became more
pitted with shell holes and as his
painting came nearer to completion
he became morose angry and exceedingly
difficult to talk to and after five or
six days in this mood he has suddenly
appeared cheerful and delighted like a
small boy at school I asked him what had
happened and he said I have been worried
because I couldn't get the shell hole
right in the paintings however I did it
he looked like a mountain but yesterday
I discovered if I put a little bit of
white in it it looked like a hole after
all it was at the end of 1921 that
Winston put down on paper his thoughts
and feelings about his passion for
painting he wrote two articles for The
Strand Magazine which became known as
painting as a pastime
he wrote the people who discover
painting in middle age do not have time
for the deliberate approach two years of
drawing lessons three years of copying
wood cuts five years of plaster casts
these are for the young they have enough
to bear and this thorough grounding is
for those who hearing the call in the
morning of their days are able to make
painting their Perriman
live from vacation we must not be too
ambitious
we cannot aspire to masterpieces we may
content ourselves with a joyride in a
paint box and for this audacity is the
only ticket he only painted in oils and
went on to say I write no word in
disparagement of watercolors but there
really is nothing like oils just to
paint his great fun the colors are
lovely to look at and delicious to
squeeze out matching them however
crudely with what you see is fascinating
and absolutely absorbing try it if you
have not done so before you die Winston
had never been to an art gallery before
1915 Clementine Churchill told how they
went to London's National Gallery that
year and he became totally absorbed in
looking at just one or two paintings and
studying the technique one of the ways
that Winston thought himself to paint
was by copying pictures that he admired
he liked the paintings of John Singer
Sargent and copied several of his
paintings including the ruins of eras
Cathedral and in January 1921 Winston
was in Paris on official business but
took the opportunity to visit gallery
drew II where the works of a new artist
one Charles Morin was being exhibited
the gallery drew a was a gallery showing
important post-impressionist pictures
and together with the head of the
British military mission and an art
critic they studied the pictures for 40
minutes they were all very impressed and
so they should have been as the artist
Charles Morin was in fact a pseudonym
for Winston himself all the pictures
sold and I unfortunately lost forever
history does not record the prices but
apart from giving one of his paintings
for auction this is the only time that
he said
paintings in about 1925 Winston entered
one of his paintings in an amateur art
exhibition and competition the condition
was that none of the paintings were too
beside so the judges did not know their
provenance Winston entered the painting
which he called winter sunshine one of
his earliest pictures the judges were so
Joseph Duveen a great patron of the Arts
and benefactor of the National Gallery
and the Tate Kenneth Clark a young man
who became one of the great art
historians and Oswald Burley the
celebrated portrait painter Oswald
Burleigh gave this account of the
judging arriving early on the scene I
managed to put out on one side all the
pictures which seemed to have any real
merit I especially noticed a picture of
a red house in some night with snow on
the roof painted with great vigor to
which I decided being still alone to
award the first prize later in the
morning when Devine arrived on showing
him my choice of first prize he
disagreed firmly saying no that is
obviously by a professional painter and
this is an amateur show I answered that
we must assume that his author was an
honest man and insisted upon it being
given first prize Kenneth Clark upheld
my choice and so it was settled and when
finally the secretary released the names
of the various Prize winners we were all
delighted and much interested to find
that Winston Churchill had painted
winter sunshine
Winston greatly appreciated advice from
different artists as well as John and
Hazel averey he painted with John Sicard
who had been a friend of Clementine
Churchill when she had lived in Dieppe
as a child with her mother Winston had
been painting for twelve years when he
first met Sicard he was at home with his
brushes paints and easel he tackled a
variety of subjects landscapes the sea
interior still lives architecture and
had even ventured into portrait painting
above all his passion for painting and
his determination to wrestle with the
techniques were unabated and his
eagerness to learn was as keen as ever
despite all his work as a politician and
a minister he missed no opportunity to
paint his paint box and paraphernalia
comforted him even on the most formal of
ministerial visits SiC had instructed
him how to prepare a canvas by creating
a cameo an underpainting of often
several layers of paint composed usually
of two colors he also taught churchill
how to use photographs to be used as
made Manoir to complete painting later
in the studio another use of the
photograph that he taught him was to
make a grid and there is a picture in
his studio charcoal called painting
lesson from mr. secret which is
constructed from a photograph and has
six handwritten instructions in the
margin and writing to sicut in October
1927 in Paris we bought for free pounds
ten shillings a splendid Lantern
apparently a trade product which froze
the positive or negative on the canvas
exactly the size one wishes this enables
the Cameo to be constructed with
extraordinary rapidity and accuracy in
four or five tenths of monochrome either
you can do it for the negative and paint
the whites black and the blacks white or
you can have a lantern slide made and
follow the values directly I've not had
a geek chance yet of trying a portrait
by this method but I'm sure that a very
fair likeness can be produced with great
certainty the splendid Lantern was to
become part of his equipment in his
studio he found it helped him to
overcome his lack of expertise as a
draftsman and using this technique
he painted portraits of friends and
family members
Churchill created one of the most
striking portraits of his beloved
Clementine painted from a photograph
taking when she launched the air
Groff carrier HMS indomitable Churchill
loved the Ragin photograph taken of her
as she waved the great ship away and the
sketch portrait is full of vitality
interestingly this self-portrait of
Clementine using the Magic Lantern
technique had one problem
Churchill's Detective Sergeant Murray
put the lantern slide into the projector
the wrong way around so this unique
painting shows Clementine in mirror
image I'm very lucky to own this special
and vibrant painting of such a
remarkable and lovely lady
I have loaned it to chart for where it
hangs a lady Churchill sitting-room
facing the wonderful portrait by it's a
hospital barely of her husband Barry
Soames said that although he used these
techniques her memories are almost
entirely of him painting directly onto
the canvas another artist who he painted
with was for Mars in October 1937 Paul
wrote him after he'd heard him speak in
a debate admirers of Collins My dear
Winston I was thrilled by every word you
said in the house yesterday as I went
down the usher said to me you chose a
good day to come he's always fine none
left like him he always does one good
I nearly embraced him I feel so much
what he said I have sent you some
brushes you should destroy most of your
old brushes which can't help you in your
work paint like you write or speak every
stroke of the brush must be a statement
felt and seen Churchill also learned
from William Nicholson he first met this
brilliant painter in 1934 when he came
to chart wall to paint a conversation
piece of wisdom and Clementine to
commemorate their silver wedding many
years later
Winston told Sir John Lawson Stein that
Winston William Nicholson was the person
who taught him most about painting
Winston loved to paint on holiday
you spent many painting holidays staying
with friends in the South of France and
in Marrakesh during the Second World War
was only painted one picture the Sun
setting over the Atlas Mountains from
Marrakech
he held a conference with President
Roosevelt for 10 days in Casablanca in
January 1943 the president was due to
fly back to the States far lagos then to
dacha across to brazil then home to
washington such a dangerous and
strenuous trip Winston at the last
moment persuaded the President to visit
Marrakech telling him that he wished to
spend two days with him to show him this
Paris of the Sahara and to wonder at the
sight of the Sun setting over the Atlas
Mountains the president was persuaded
Winston supplied the picnic and the
hundred and fifty mile journey across
the desert into the hills began life was
different then and the dangers immense
the five hour drive was spent in both
serious and light-hearted discussion the
route was guarded by literally thousands
of American troops and when they stopped
beside the road for a picnic armoured
personnel carriers tommy gun carrying
soldiers and GI surrounded them an
aircraft circled above probably the most
bizarre picnic in the history of the
world they arrived at Marrakech staying
at the Villa Taylor that evening the
president was carried in a chair up to
the roof of the Tower of the villa where
they enjoyed the splendor of the Sun
setting over the snow-covered Atlas
mountain they had a fine dinner with
lots of laughter and singing Churchill
sang a solo and the president was about
to but was interrupted the next day the
day of departure of the President dawned
Winston was still in bed where the
president wanted to leave unperturbed
Winston jumped out of bed dressed in his
brilliant red dressing gown with dragons
on the back and a pair of bedroom
slippers and came downstairs to face a
farewell to his friend at the last
moment had tired as he was
he drove to the airport with him he even
going onto the plane to settle the
present and admiring the courage of this
fine man
with his physical disabilities Winston
returned to the villa and painted the
view across Marrakesh to the slow he
atlas mountains and later presented this
fine and new unique painting to the
president and this painting has now been
sold and is gone to Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie and they very kindly
exhibiting it quite soon at an
Exhibition in celui Missouri and a
parent has been cleaned and it looks
wonderful after the war tired and
disappointed having lost the election he
borrowed a house on the shores of Lake
Como from his friend Earl Alexander the
wartime general Sarah Churchill in her
wonderful little book of Fred in the
tapestry says in a letter to her mother
that when Alex came to the house to
visit Winston they talked painting most
of the time she writes last night I
heard them wandering around the house
theoretically touching up the positively
frightful pictures there and proposed
saying
now come here Alex come here and I
really look at this we really paint
better than the pastor that painted this
one and Sarah goes on to say I really
think that he is over it it's hard to
tell but he said last night every state
day I stay here without news without
worry
I realized more and more the truth of
what your mother said a blessing in
disguise the war is over it is one and
they have lifted the hideous aftermath
from my shoulders I am what I never
thought I would be until my grave sauce
susie is so regret the only thing he
misses is you and writing to his
daughter Mary he wrote at the same time
here it is sunshine and calm I paint all
day and every day and have banished
karynda's
to the shades annex painted too he is
very good in the house Sarah writes
there were indeed some perfectly
frightful pictures and one above all he
sat and stared at every evening it was
of a stagnant murky pool and reflected
some funeral shrubbery two sombre fir
trees blotted out much of the sky which
looked reminiscent of a London Fog and
peering out busy asleep between the
trees was a pale and sickly Sun that
picture became the butt and focus of
Alex and my father the evening they were
together and after Alex had left papar
was still sitting staring as usual at
the offending picture when suddenly
turning to us he said we are all agreed
are we not that this is the worst
picture that has ever been painted
we murmur dissent it takes the palm the
prize for bad pictures you must say it's
offensive
again we nodded our ascent in a
twinkling of an eye the picture was off
the wall was prized out of its frame and
was being carried triumphantly up to the
bathroom which was being used as a
studio to be doctored Charles Morin
groaned he oughtn't to do it he oughtn't
to do it oughtn't he I asked no said
Charles but you won't stop him and
taking up the banner of passive
resistance went off to bed I left
upstairs where my father was squeezing
great dogs of vivid color I delivered my
lecture you really mustn't I said as the
first vivid red hit the gloomy canvas my
voice trailed away suddenly beautiful
flaming azaleas appeared on the dingy
shrubbery but dingy furs were given back
the new queen of their youth the pallid
sun instead of trying to break through
the fog with fitful gleam sank in a
splurge of glory and the folk as if by
magic disappeared and the happiest of
blue skies smiled down on the whole
scene which had been caught by the
hitherto stagnant repellent pool now
kaleidoscope of reflection it was
breathtaking
it was enchanting it was lovely the
whole thing accomplished and back in its
frame and back on the wall inside half
an hour we sat at mardik for two hours
exhausted but satisfied by this act of
artistic rape as my father called it an
early next morning one by one we tipped
our town to have a look
what would the morning reveal well do
you know he was still lovely he glowed
brazenly like a bird of paradise and we
were all brokenhearted when he was once
more carried upstairs to have its face
washed and he now hangs back on the wall
stagnant and as gloomy as before in 1947
Churchill was to achieve a goal he could
certainly never have imagined the
president of the Royal Academy sir
Alfred Manning's
suggested he should enter some of his
paintings for hanging in the roll
Academy's summer exhibition Churchill
after some persuasion agreed but said
they should be entered under a pseudonym
the pictures he chose but winter
sunshine was the one that had won the
earlier competition and the Lu River
which he had painted in the 30s he send
them in under the name David winter he
was only once they had been accepted
that they tell he told him there were
his real name the following year he
entered free paintings this time under
his name and later the Royal Academy
elected to him an honorary academician
extraordinary this was an honor that he
greatly prized in December 1950 after a
figures election campaign winter
sunshine and the prospect of painting
beckoned so he returned to Marrakech he
had discovered a new and fascinating
place to paint tinerhir
which he described a Clementine as as
sunlight painting paradise to get to
this valley of great gorges of marble
and redstone required a flight over the
Atlas Mountains the party of 14
including Clementine and Diana
nearly didn't make it as one of the
party water Graebner was to describe
Churchill always smoked on takeoffs but
this time as the plane raced down the
runway he decided to take no chances and
tried to ram his burning six-inch cigar
into the receptacle on the arm of his
chair and when he found that cigar was
too big for the ashtray he lifted the
metal container out of the arm
depositing the cigar in the hole
replacing the container and settled down
for a snooze hardly had the plane left
the ground and started the shop climb
over the Atlas Mountains when the smell
of burning cigar presented permeated the
cabin and a cloud of smoke enveloped him
he realized something was wrong and
called the stewardess together they
discovered the source of the fire and in
a few minutes enough water was poured
down the hole to extinguish it but
Churchill was determined to make doubly
sure the fire was really out grabbing
his steel Prag Walkingstick he proceeded
to ram it down the hole and bash the
cigar at the bottom still not satisfied
he sent for one of the officers and
demanded that the cigar be retrieved
when this was done he announced now we
can go over the mountain although
Winston painted many landscapes he also
painted a considerable number of still
lives flower paintings and interiors as
well as portraits I loved his flower
paintings and also the many trees that
he painted his paintings are a wonderful
record of the private part of his life
of the places that he visited the houses
like Blenheim Palace charcoal and Trent
park which meant so much to him and also
the portraits of his family and friends
Churchill love bright colors he said I
rejoice with the brilliant ones and I'm
genuinely sorry for the four Browns
when I get to heaven I mean to spend a
considerable portion of my first million
years in
painting I expect orange and Vermillion
will be the darkest Dulles colors there
will be a whole range of wonderful new
colors which will delight this Lester I
this unknown sights this great man his
painting gave such an enormous pleasure
to him seeing him through good times and
bad times dark days and bright days his
books and speeches are well known his
paintings less-known he painted over 500
pictures which he referred to as his
dogs and I've spent six years tracing
them from collections around the world
for my book this has been an enormous
pleasure to me but now the task has been
with a few exceptions completed I was so
pleased to be able to place in digital
format at Churchill College Cambridge as
an addition to the great archive of his
papers and speeches his paintings for 40
years
it gained so much pleasure from his
pastime from the moment that he walked
in the garden at how farm cast down with
misery by the catastrophe of the
Dardanelles his life was changed
he wrote happier the painters for they
shall not be lonely
light in color peace and hope will keep
them company to the end or almost to the
end of the day thank you so much and now
with Simon's help we're going to show
you some examples of his paintings thank
you
thank you very much many I will start my
little part of the presentation with one
of these wonderful and there are so many
of them till Churchill stories and this
particular one Churchill had had a
meeting not quite sure where it was but
I think was on a ship or somewhere or
other and Churchill was in a little
cabin with the door open and sitting on
the bed literally in his you we call
them Underpants you call them I don't
know what but in his underpants and a
vest and this G I came to the door and
said hey fatso where's the John
Churchill sort of glowered at him and
thought for a moment and he replied you
leave my cabin
you turn left it's the second door on
the right it's the one that says
gentlemen but don't be put off by that I
I love these stories I wish they were
all true we can start a presentation of
some of his paintings and the very first
painting I've got a monitor here I can
see is it how far where he started to
paint so this is actually one of his
very very first paintings many talked
about how he stayed there with his
sister-in-law who she called Guney which
was her pet name but Gwendolyn married
to Winston's brother and for a first
painting I think it's pretty special
when many was doing the book we we
wanted to search through four
photographs to mix them in with the
paintings photographs of him actually
painting and this is the only one we
found with actually Clementine in the
picture with him and many mentioned that
Winston went off to the trenches in the
first world war he was always an
individual and thought for himself he
didn't like a British officers tin
helmet he liked a French officers tin
helmet and so this is him in a French
officers helmet
and if you go to chart tool you will
actually see that very helmet on the
wall together with a painting of him in
may in the helmet lovely many also
mentioned Lawrence farm where he was
he's actually popped himself into this
picture and you can just see him in the
foreground
I must actually say that you cannot
appreciate these pictures in this sort
of format you really do have to see the
originals they're so vibrant and vibrant
in color
you know if somebody took a photograph
of me and it was sort of forty feet five
feet wide and 20 feet high or something
I'd look pretty awful but pictures
should be seen in their right
proportions but it gives you a pretty
good idea and many also mentioned about
how he tried to get the shell holes in
the in the side of buildings which were
happening while he was painting and this
is the little bit of white that he put
around to make it look as that was a
hole rather than the mountain and they
you can see the artillery explosions
there
I just calmly sitting there painting I
mean can you believe it I mean he also
talked about winter shot and sunshine
that he put him to the competition this
never reproduces very well but if you go
to chart well and I'm sure a lot of you
who have gone to chart or you'll see it
in lady Churchill sitting room just over
to the right of the fireplace and it
really is a beautiful beautiful picture
but this does not do it justice and many
also talked about this wonderful
portrait of Lady Churchill launching HMS
indomitable taken from a photograph from
the Telegraph this is the one that went
in back to front and there's a quite an
amusing story about it when many moved
from west from intent down to Lyme Regis
and Dorset she'd asked the National
Trust if they would like to borrow it
from her because she was concerned that
it would get stolen or the CI would
affect it and it's such a special
picture I actually think it's the the
best picture that Churchill ever painted
because it's the one that is so most
dear to him anyway we rank chart well
and they wanted to have
picture and they said would we deliver
it round after the house house closed so
we bugged it in the boot of the or the
trunk of the car and drove around to
chart fall lots of people came out with
white gloves horrified that we just sort
of bugged it into the boot of the car
anyway they took it from us with their
white gloves and said that they would
put it up after the house had closed the
following morning there was a tour group
going around led by a person who'd taken
probably a thousand tours around the
house and he stood with his back to wear
this now painting was hanging and he
explained all the pictures in the room
and then he said and behind me as an old
Turkey and he was doing really well up
until that point and he could see the
expression on people's face so for the
first time he'd turned round and saw
this beautiful picture where in fact
they had previously been a painting of
an old Turkey that had looked as though
it had been in a really bad fight and
lost and it had been replaced with this
one he said I'm so sorry I've never seen
that picture before anyway it's it's
there now but lady Churchill also must
have loved it because on the back of the
canvas it's got written this was painted
by my husband
Clementine s Churchill and if you think
about it
Clementine would have only ever seen
herself in this view one only sees
oneself in the mirror to see yourself in
mirror image not the right way around
and so this is the way she saw and so
hopefully she loved it
Marrakesh I'm going to go through quite
quickly because we're running out of
time
many talked about Lake Como this is one
of the pictures from Alexander general
Alexander's house on Lake Como and
Minnie and I were going way to Brazil on
one occasion and Minnie son Jack let us
know that the picture painted by
Alexander was coming up for sale at
Christie's so many said well for
goodness sake if you can buy it please
buy it and on the back of the canvas it
says painted with Winston Churchill Lake
Como September 1945
anyway Jack bid Fritz and
and so many was terribly pleased to have
it and she immediately loaned it to
charville and these two pictures the one
painted by Alex and the one babe painted
this one by Sir Winston now hangs
side-by-side where they were originally
when they were when they were painted so
it's nice that they both are now joined
together lovely water scenes this is
tinny here which Minnie talked about and
a copy of a Sargent painting the ruins
of Eros Cathedral and a sir a foggy
Roehampton not trent Park he's eager
Park and the pyramids of course in Egypt
I think was 1923 as Colonial Secretary
he went to Egypt and he painted three or
four pictures of the pyramids on that
particular visit then went on to
Jerusalem sorry this is still in in
Egypt the wonderful picture of Sir
Winston just here and just and Lawrence
of Arabia on the right and lots of other
very distinguished people but after this
picture was taken
they had a race around the pyramids and
Sir Winston or Winston fell off his
camel but remounted and finished the
race and then he went on to Jerusalem
and in this wonderful sunset over
Jerusalem which is a really pretty
picture and interestingly it was on this
trip that it was decided that the
borders of Iraq would be JA would be
drawn isn't it dreadful how people just
drew lines on a map with a ruler and a
and a pencil and said that's a country
and it was it was Winston who was almost
demanding that a separate country be
given to the Kurds what a wonderful
thing if that had actually happened but
the Foreign Office would not allow it
and the tapestries of Blenheim lovely
photograph him painting and he loved the
architecture of this sort of painting
it's also Gwendolyn
in the in the picture or Guney Trent
Park this belongs to Prince Charles and
this is Wilton that belongs to the Queen
we did check on the Prince Charles one
and that's in hi at Highgrove in theirs
best guestroom and the Queen's this was
given to Lord George and his owned by a
friend of ours been cleaned it's
beautiful
but he loved painting trees and he loved
painting water more trees mm-hmm
Lake Swasey lovely trees and water and
trees this is the fontaine de vaucluse
in the South of France
lovely lovely River which we went to
recently with Mary and there was a
lovely story he set his easel he said
his canvas up to paint had a wonderful
little spot to paint this wonderful
River and his very shallow River with
with growth green growth in the bottom
so in the sunlight is the most beautiful
sight anyway was all set up ready to
paint when this was a tap on his
shoulder and this very angry French lady
said to him - would you mind getting out
of the way that was her spot to wash her
clothes and I think they came to some
sort of arrangement and the clothes were
washed and the painting was painted and
another one of our clues another one of
our clues but while he was there he was
told that he could actually go and visit
the source of the river just up there
the hill and he was fairly in firmness
was painted in the 50s and the only form
of transport that could get up the hill
was a donkey that was used to pull the
trash cart around the village and the
donkey went by the most wonderful name
of Jacques Allah so shocked Allah was
taken off trash duty for that day and
carried Winston or Sir Winston as he was
then up to the top of the mountain and
also brought him down and the following
day went back to shifting trash and we
actually went there and we saw
photographs of him on the donkey and we
have
those poor donkey another Vaucluse
but once again he loved painting water
and trees Venice I'm nipping through
very quickly now because I'm sure there
are questions that you want to ask I
love this particular picture one of my
favorites but if you actually look at it
the perspective is wonderful you want to
walk along that path but you've got the
river on the right you've got the the
medium distant fields with the town
behind and the mountains behind and it's
wonderful wonderful picture the nuns of
the beckon arch at Bruges and grace
Hamlin who a lot of you will know about
one of his secretaries said that the
nuns were made to walk up and down for
seven hours she wasn't too jolly and
that would be the this is the photograph
that he would have taken back to his
studio to finish the painting so the
original painting is there and you can
see how he's very close to it but grace
Hamlin as I said was one of his
secretaries and would often sit with
church a while he was painting and was
very close to Churchill and one day
sitting at her desk at Chartwell Sir
Winston arrived with a painting in his
hands and he said grace you've always
said you loved my pictures as this one
is for you and unfortunately the
reaction on Grace's face was not what
Sir Winston was expecting so he said
grace what's what's the problem do you
not like my paintings no she said I love
your paintings but not that one so I
said well which one do you like
and so she pointed to the nuns the
begginers of Bruges and she said I loved
that one so he said well I suppose you
better have it then
anyway when Grace who said chart full up
as it were as the house was in the 30s
when she retired she had been living in
one of the cottages of chart wall and
the only asset that she had to be able
to buy a house was his painting
Clementine Churchill was still alive and
so grace asked her
she were if her husband would mind if
she sold his painting that was given to
her I'm Clementine said he would be
thrilled to bits
anyway the painting was sold it was sold
in New York and it was bought by
somebody called Arthur Murray the school
of dance and so he bought the picture
and when we were doing the book I was
trying to make contact with the Murray
family and I just couldn't make any
contact at all except on the internet
and there was a little box on the
Internet
thing to contact Arthur Murray School of
Dance you know that one way you booked
your tango lessons and so I said we were
doing this book etc etc and in a couple
of days later we got an email back from
one of the twin daughters of Arthur
Murray and they said yes we still have
the picture and so they mini was having
a conversation over the email with his
lovely daughter Jane and Jane asked
where where they could see other
pictures by Churchill and Minnie
mentioned chart wall and they said they
were going to come over to England and
many said well that's lovely we'd love
to show you around sharp wool well we
had tickets booked for the Chelsea
Flower Show that day we have to give
those up and we went down to charville
and met them and she'd said the previous
evening that she was going to bring her
driver down I think she meant a husband
anyway we got down to chart four and
they were in the little restaurant there
and the driver stood up or the husband
and he kept on going and he was about
six foot seven and it was dr. Henry
Heimlich you know the Heimlich maneuver
and he was the person who had invented
or thought about the Heimlich maneuver
and saved over a million lives so very
interesting little stories we had in
gathering the pictures together
wonderful picture with all his
paraphernalia I'm going to go very
quickly now
this is a wonderful photograph and I'm
going to show you the next slide because
that is the picture that he's painting
in the photograph and when he's very
lucky she actually owns this photograph
but the actual painting this one is a
view of her uncle's house down on the
Mediterranean at captai and one day her
uncle came by and said gosh that's
wonderful you've got a painting of my
house so even more special to have that
painting French little French port in
the South of France this is like a pond
chena the home of Lord Beaverbrook just
outside Monte Carlo another scene
painting up in Marrakesh and the
koutoubia mosque in marrakech this is
the picture that is now owned by Brad
Pitt and Angelina Jolie this looks like
a lonely painting a lonely photograph
but what one doesn't see in the
photograph is the 1,000 people standing
behind him while he's painting and it
looks totally peaceful lovely seascape
but a little bus this is the bus made by
Neiman commissioned by the Queen Neiman
was commissioned by the Queen to do a
bust of Churchill but Churchill I'm
afraid was a bit of a fidget and was not
a good sitter and so they made a deal
that if Neiman taught Churchill how to
sculpt Churchill will sit still and be
sculpted by Neiman and this was the
sculpture that Churchill did of Nieman
Neiman actually has a little pointy
beard that's why it's got a rather long
chin and once again this came up for
sale and young Jack Minnie's younger son
bought it at the auction and so he now
has it but this is very special it's the
only sculpture of the Church of ever did
and Neiman had it cast
bronze and you can put your fingers into
the finger holes where Churchill hood
had actually done the bust mmm lovely
magnolias III have to just take a little
moment on this particular picture I was
reminded the other day of the wonderful
book the dream and I'm sure a lot of you
have read the book recently published
and I don't know if you know the story
of the dream I've got to go back one
picture this is over on the right of the
picture is a painting of of Winston's
father Lord Randolph and he was trying
to make a copy in the studio and while
he was making a copy so I almost go on
in the red armchair appeared his father
Lord Randolph I'm sure everybody number
of people know this story so please
forgive me and he literally appeared in
front of Winston this was in 1957 I
think something like that a 1947 and
Winston was painting as I said in the in
the studio and his father suddenly
appeared and they had a long
conversation and the conversation was
all about what was going on in the world
since Lord Randolph had died and they
told Winston told about the First World
War and the Second World War and
dreadful disasters and who was on the
throne and all sorts of things that were
going on in the world and I just wanted
to read this very last bit of the dream
so Lord Randolph says to Winston Winston
you have told me a terrible tale I would
never have believed that such things
could happen I'm glad I did not did not
live to see them as I listened to you
unfolding these fearful fire
you seem to know a great deal about them
and I might say that when when Winston's
father suddenly appeared Lord Randolph
said to Winston ah so you became a
painter but this is the end bit and I'll
continue as I listen to listen to you
unfolding these fearful facts you seem
to know a great deal about them I never
expected that you would develop so far
and so fully of course you are old now
you're too old now to think about such
things but when I hear you talk
I really wonder you didn't go into
politics you might have done a lot to
help you might even have made a name for
yourself isn't it beautiful and this is
Winston in this dream and he wrote it
down and he was asked whether it was
true or not and he would never answer
but it was the way that the son was
trying to get that credit from a loving
father that he'd never been able to
express and I think those are such
personal word words but in the story of
the dream he still wasn't able to say I
became Prime Minister I saved the world
but it's a lovely book and if anybody
has never read it do try and get hold of
a copy of it chart wall I'm going to go
very quickly through because you want
some questions a wonderful bottle scape
at Chartwell the black swans a gift from
the Australian government that all the
lakes at Chartwell were built by
Churchill himself with a wonderful steel
steam-powered digger the papal palace at
Avignon more water south coast of France
of cassis the calanque south of France
so after France sorry to whistle through
but you must all go and see the
originals
lovely little French port we went there
with Mary and it's still very similar
love the children walking down these are
a parapet little bit there lovely
photograph you see Sir Winston painting
and a detective behind him and the
driver sitting over reading a book south
of France but five hundred and forty
pictures I think if if you're a
professional artist would have been some
some going there we are well I hope you
enjoyed that and I know we run out of
time
and one thing I wanted to say is we we
are so blessed to have been invited over
here and I think that you are extremely
lucky you have got some of the most
wonderful people Richard and Barbara
langworth who I think have been involved
with Churchill things for very nearly 50
years and now of course you have Larry
on who the two of them I think are the
two Churchill heroes that are leading
leading this country in the knowledge of
Churchill and to be finishing the
biography is something exceptionally
special because that is the real source
and so many people are writing books
about Churchill and getting so many
things wrong that is absolutely
wonderful to have the accuracy that it
is being produced here and I thank you
very very much indeed and now if anybody
would like any questions immediately
following this session mrs. Churchill
has agreed to inscribe several copies of
her book and that will be directly on
the other side of this curtain we now
have time for one or two questions but
mrs. Churchill will be able to answer
further questions at following this
session
nobody has any questions yes thank you
I have hope this is not a crass question
but I'm just curious if any of sir
Winston's paintings have sold at auction
and what sort of prices that they would
bring well it just depends but there was
a very big auction this time last year
of lady Soames is estate and one of her
paintings the one of the goldfish pond
went for 1.8 1.8 million pounds but a
lot of them go for about a hundred and
fifty thousand pounds two hundred
thousand pounds but recently some have
gone for quite high prices this will be
our final question about how long would
it take Sir Winston to do one of his
typical paintings I mean some artists
take three and four years obviously he
must have done it much faster than that
but what's typical I think what happened
very often was that he would start
painting in the South of France or
Marrakesh or wherever he happened to be
but he would also have some photographs
taken and he would take the canvases
back and complete them in his studio at
Chartwell during the winter months and
he did finish an awful lot of the
pictures I mean they are all very well
finished and he built the studio himself
there and it's a wonderful studio if you
get the chance go to chart wall and
you'll see so many of the paintings
there and we're so happy that the
National Trust has so many of these
pictures because they'll remain there
forever and you know it's incredible how
he wrote so many books painted more than
500 canvases as well as being Prime
Minister and doing so many other
important things remarkable man there's
a very
very interesting thing happened
immediately after the war somebody in
Japan got hold of painting as a pastime
and a lot of the very sort of top
industrialists people in the government
and writers and these sorts of people
got together and they said if this man
with all the things that he did could
paint painting probably made him a
better man
and they formed a Japanese club called a
Churchill Kai Japanese for club and I
believe there are over 70 Churchill
Kai's across Japan now and they have a
big exhibition every year and it's still
the sort of top journalists the authors
the industrialists who join these clubs
absolutely amazing immediately after the
war and if you think that the second
atomic bomb was named after Churchill is
quite something